lady gaga is officially off the market I
have not heard about that et can
confirmed the 32 year old entertainer is
engaged to longtime love Christian
Kirino a source tells ET quote gaga
seems very happy to be in a more low-key
relationship than with Taylor Kinney
she's on top of the world and Christian
is part of that I don't know if I have
the articulate words to describe you
know the tremendous feeling of
overwhelming joy and excitement the pop
star and actress revealed the exciting
news Monday night when she called
Christian my fiance while making a
speech at an event in Beverly Hills she
stepped out rocking a pink diamond ring
on that special finger on the red carpet
Gaga has warned the massive sparkler
many times during her press tour for a
star is born
mother monster was previously engaged to
Chicago Fire star Taylor Kinney before
calling it quits in 2016
she later confirmed her relationship
with Christian a talent manager in
February 2017 the two weren't shy about
their romance kissing and cuddling ahead
of Gaga's Super Bowl halftime
performance well it's not just about it
being my boyfriend I I asked that of
many
my family all the time that's mother
monster praising her then-boyfriend for
giving his input when it comes to her
career and it's clear Christian is her
biggest fan
he shares PDA filled pics on Instagram
with Gaga as the lovebirds travel
together he posted this cozy snap of the
pair and captioned it quote home is not
where you are from it is where you
belong some of us travel the whole world
to find it others find it in a person
and this stripped down pic of Gaga that
simply read believe in fairytales a
hundred people can be in a room in 99
don't believe in you and just one person
believes in you and it can change
everything
[Music]
[Applause]